[Musique]
jacques chesnais bienvenus bonjour
installez-vous merci beaucoup pour le
café politique vous êtes le tout nouveau
secrétaire départemental du parti
socialiste tout juste élu au tout début
du mois d'avril je reprends les chiffres
au 1er tour vous êtes arrivé en tête
devant le maire de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines jean claude
husson et le conseiller d'opposition de
maurepas ismaila vannes vous aviez déjà
47,5 pour cent des voix votre opposant a
donc choisi de se retirer au deuxième
tour unique candidat vous avez été élu
cette élection et ce résultat vous vous
y attendiez écoutez le j'ai m'attendais
à peu près à obtenir ce pourcentage
peut-être même un peu plus puisque on a
loupé la main la majorité absolue à
hassi loi mais on peut toujours revenir
sur ce qui s'est passé mais l'intérêt
c'est de savoir que grâce à cette
élection
la fédération des yvelines parti
socialiste qui est certes affaiblie
j'imagine qu'on va en parler
se réunit j'ai autour de moi
proposer notre conseil fédéral quatre
adjoints jeunes qui représentent les
quatre textes d'orientation et que nous
avions
donc que nous devions choisir donc
contre les fédérer réunir sa lutte et je
pense que pendant de très longues années
le parti socialiste était imparti de
synthèse où on trouvait le plus grand
dénominateur commun de façon à
travailler ensemble et travailler
justement
et puis il s'est passé un événement il
ya maintenant quelques années puisque
c'était en 2005 où malheureusement on
est venu un parti où on a fait un
référendum interne vous rappeler c'était
sur l'europe soit disant la constitution
européenne
je veux dire très clairement j'étais
pour le non mais ça divisé le parti
profondément et depuis cette époque là
au lieu de travail et à la synthèse et à
convaincre nos concitoyens des solutions
que nous leur proposions auquel
s'étaient bonne pour notre pays
on s'est plutôt déchiré on en paye le
prix a flambé mais l'idée c'est de
retourner et c'est là c'est même
l'objectif même de l'art du texte
d'orientation pour lequel
que j'ai choisi c'est même son objectif
c'est de retravailler à refaire cette
synthèse entre nous vous reprenez une
fédération qui ne va pas forcément très
bien à peu près 300 adhérents qui sont à
jour de cotisation sur la structure
sortir les maçons ou de 300 qui soit
jour de cotisation de lukas ce sont à
peu près 300 effets qui sont venus voter
qui sont venus voter a surpris à chaque
fois ce soit toujours les mêmes
d'ailleurs parce que on n'est pas
toujours présent que des camarades très
proche de moi qui étais même pas là pour
le voter pour moi par exemple loyer
parce qu'on a tous des obligations à un
moment donné l'activité militante c'est
pas une activité professionnelle vont en
tout cas une fédération qui va qui va
plutôt mal vous pouvez la succession de
sandrine gang qui a été écarté et qui
maintenant a rejoint le mouvement de
benoît hamon génération point s
cette division de la gauche cette ce
passage de benoît hamon aussi ça fait ça
fait du mal au parti socialiste
alors ça forcément fait du mal mais je
vais revenir légèrement au dessus j'ai
un petit peu vous situer ce que je
faisais était jusqu'à présent trésorier
de la fédération donc déjà dans une
direction entre guillemets hamonistes
parce qu'on avait la particularité c'est
ce que nous explique à juste avant d'une
fois qu'il y avait une majorité des
cartes et un peu les autres j'étais dans
cette majorité et j'étais très j'ai pas
suivi benoît hamon
sandrine grande ce que je regrette
d'ailleurs a été écartée pour des
raisons qui n'ont strictement rien à
voir avec ce qui s'est passé au sein du
parti socialiste
elle a rejoint génération
c'est évidemment regrettable que divisée
que ce soit disait il ya une centaine de
militants qui sont partis à grand bruit
parce que c'est un peu logique on veut
concret un mouvement où on veut se
différencier c'est aussi un peu le
danger il faut aussi que nous on se
retiennent dans ce sens là c'est à dire
que vous re toujours se situer par
rapport à nos entre guillemets
concurrent alors qu'à un moment donné on
va devoir forcément travailler ensemble
sur les prochaines échéances
peut-être pas les européennes parce que
malheureusement je crains qu'elle ne
serve dont chaque partie à se compter a
compté ses formes ce qui est qui va être
profondément dommageable parce que
il ya un vrai un vrai problème l'europe
c'est quelque chose extrêmement
important pour nous socialistes ce qui
aussi nous différencie de certaines
autres forces qui était de gauche mais
qui se disent en dehors de la gauche
bizarrement maintenant mais je suis tout
à fait confiance dans notre capacité à
travailler ensemble même s'il est
évidemment trop tôt pour en parler plus
pour s'avancer beaucoup plus vous avez
67 ans vous êtes membre du parti
socialiste depuis 40 ans il a bien
évolué ce parti qu'est ce qui vous a
motivé il ya 40 ans quels sont les
figures qui vous ont fait rejoindre le
parking sociale écoutez je veux ça peut
paraître étrange mais l époque
d'abord premièrement je ne suis pas un
homme
la preuve ce que j'ai pas suivi benoît
même je ne suis pas d'accord avec sa
stratégie
mais à l'époque je suis rentré
pas poursuivre mais parce que j'ai
commencé à militer parties saisissent tu
as lucian j'habitais et c'était le
creuset de la circonscription de l'est
cas de michel rocard
donc j'ai commencé au parti ces listes
en tant qu rocardien et à l'époque je
m'estime est déjà à la gauche du parti
socialiste
j'ai pas beaucoup changé sur mes
engagements et en particulier par
exemple sur l'importance que doit
prendre pour les socialistes
l'entreprise
je suis je viens du privé moi j'ai
toujours travaillé dans le privé
j'étais directeur financier d'une
société donc le public je défends
profondément le service public c'est
aussi un dans notre adn de socialistes
mais j'ai aussi une grande attention à
ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'entreprise
nous allons fêter les 40 ans de mai 68
ouais c'est ça mais pas si longtemps 50
ans c'est ça que gentil de me rajeunir
nova sur votre âge et puis en mai soit
son prix fort bien soixante et soixante
dix huit ans j'étais
au lycée aller qu'on appelait à l'époque
léon des loyers mais qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui je le dis stoecklin saint
germain en laye j j'étais très engagé
mais pas dans le mouvement dans le
mouvement de mai 68 mais dans aucun de
ces groupes d'extrême gauche qui qui se
profilait déjà à l'époque et que j'ai
rencontrés très souvent à universités
puisque je fais des études à nanterre
après
mais j'étais en effet c'est le début de
ma rencontre avec nos politiques et
depuis je continue à mon niveau
jusqu'à présent j'ai pas des
responsabilités fonctionnelles de
trésorier mais j'ai jamais occupé des
responsabilités politiques
je continue à militer pour saisir
voulait revenir sur votre âge
oui parce que ça peut paraître étrange à
67 ans de
de prendre ce type de responsabilité en
réalité
je pense que c'est aussi une garantie
pour mes camarades que c'est pas une
carrière politique que je commencerai
jusqu'à présent les premiers secrétaires
fédéraux de tous les partis c'était une
sorte de marchepied ouais moi c'est pas
du tout mon objectif
j'ai pas dans trois ans croyez-moi je
reviendrai au militantisme de base vous
passera la main et je passerai la main
mais c'est certain c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que j'ai choisi de m'entourer
et esprit de synthèse de m'entourer de
quatre jeunes premier secrétaire fédéral
adjoint pour justement que par forcément
l'un des quatre dans tous les cas que la
main se passer aux jeunes aujourd'hui le
nouveau responsable national du parti
socialiste sa ligne vous satisfait pas
totalement ses scènes que j'ai c'est une
ligne lui aussi alors c'est très clair
je pense lui aussi mais pour certains
les députés mais je crois que
contrairement à
à beaucoup d'hommes politiques je doute
qu'ils ne se rase le matin en espérant
devenir président de la république
le texte que j'ai voté et qu'il a dont
il le premier signataire j'ai pas le
dire qu'il a écrit tout c'est un texte
qui remet le parti socialiste dans une
dans la réflexion d'abord là
donc c'est reconstruire une
un parti c'est d'abord leur maître
on travaille sur ses propres idées et
c'est ça que nous allons faire auxquels
nous avons participé dans les yeux avant
d'arriver sur la fin de l'émission est
de vous poser le traditionnel
questionnaire je voudrais juste savoir
si aujourd'hui comme comme socialiste
vous vous voir vous avez encore
confiance en l'avenir du parti
socialiste on dit le parti socialiste
mort aujourd'hui
certains aimeraient bien tous les cas et
certains s'y emploie je vais pas vous
faire la liste de ceux qui cherchent et
évidemment d'ailleurs à prendre la place
qu'occupe est parti socialiste on a bien
oeuvré il va dire tous je veux pas dire
que c'est une un crâne particulièrement
mais on a tous le vrai dans ce sens là
parce qu'on a laissé faire nous on a
même participé mais je crois pas du tout
qu'il est mort parce que les idées qu'on
défend européenne sociale démocratique
république alteirac eux
sont pas exactement dans l'adn de tous
les partis dont les militants nous sont
parfois proches mais qui ont des
positions extrêmement bizarre vous savez
moi j'ai bien connu à la gauche du parti
mélenchon part je sais comment il
fonctionne
j'ai forcément connues j'ai été même pas
à ses proches
en tous les cas des proches de benoît
hamon
je pense que ou par contre là nous
pouvons très bien travailler ensemble y
compris au niveau de l'organisation même
de ce mouvement et
je connais je suis issu d'une famille
dont mourad père était communiste
donc je connais aussi très bien là
le parti communiste est là aussi je
crois qu'il ya des possibilités
en ce moment je dirais qu'on n'est pas
forcément en odeur de sainteté pour
auprès de ses mouvements mais il n'en
est complètement différent vous parle d'
entité voyez quand il s'agit d'hommes de
femmes de femmes et d'hommes dans les
communes dans les
organismes divers ou siégeant ensemble
les choses sont complètement différentes
et donc je suis en effet de l'espoir ça
veut pas dire forcément que les choses
peuvent pas très mal se terminer
on a vu des parties
quasiment disparaître qui survivent avec
très peu de militants
les radis cours le parti communiste
malheureusement et le pays sus
deux questions rapides pour terminer
votre livre de chevet alors peut-être
vous surprendre mais en ce moment je
suis en train de lire un livre en dehors
de quelques romans policiers parce que
je lis plusieurs livres à la fois
je suis en train de lire le livre de
jean louis debré qui s'appelle ce que je
ne pouvais pas dire je cible aussi ou
gardez qui est très intéressant sur
l'amour sa liberté tout ancien président
du conseil constitionnel ils crient
pendant cette période là et c'est son
journal et on découvre on découvre en
fait les dessous des relations de ces
politiques de relire niveau de l'état
bien sûr et le dernier film que vous
ayez vu alors c'est pentagone papers
très très bon film sur sur les dessous
aussi là mais de la politique américaine
merci beaucoup aux actionnaires d'avoir
par merci à ce café politique
merci encore
[Musique]
oui
et